[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis guten Abend und willkommen im
Sport gibt's Fußball von Robert Lehmann
ein schönen guten Abend auch von mir
unsere großen
Themen Sarah Wagenknecht macht Ernst die
Politikerin will 2024 eine neue Partei
gründen und könnte damit die
Parteienlandschaft ordentlich
durcheinander wir
Krieg im Nahen Osten die Angriffe im
Gazastreifen gehen weiter gleichzeitig
kommt dort weitere Hilfe für die
Zivilbevölkerung
an und frischer Wind bei der IG Metall
mit Christiane Benner steht zum ersten
Mal eine Frau an der Spitze der größten
Gewerkschaft in
Deutschland sie war bisher eine der
bekanntesten Politikerin der Linken
jetzt hat Sarah Wagenknecht alles in die
Wege geleitet für die Gründung einer
eigenen Partei heute wurde dafür schon
mal ein Verein präsentiert mit dem Namen
bündnisara Wagenknecht insgesamt zehn
Bundestagsabgeordnete der Linken sind
dabei sie alle sind jetzt aus der linken
ausgetreten ihre Bundestagsmandate
wollen sie allerdings behalten was von
der Linkspartei heftig kritisiert wird
bis Jahresende wollen die zehn
Abgeordneten weiter in der Fraktion der
Linken bleiben treten sie dort aus wäre
deren Fraktionsstatus dahin denn dafür
braucht es im Bundestag derzeit
37 Abgeordnete momentan hat die Linke 38
die Partei könnte nur noch als
sogenannte Gruppe weitermachchen das
bedeutet weniger Recht im Bundestag und
weniger Geld Karl Hinterleitner
berichtet es ist der Anfang der
wagenknechtpartei und ein harter Schlag
für die Linke Sarah Wagenknecht meint
die Linke sei nicht mehr wählbar sie
biete keine Alternative zur
Bundesregierung deren Politik sie als
disaster ansieht ausgerechnet in dieser
Zeit hat die Bundesrepublik die wohl
schlechteste Regierung ihrer Geschichte
eine Regierung die planlos kurzsichtig
und in Teilen schlicht inkompetent
auftritt und handelt wagenknechts themen
sind unter anderem Energiepolitik
soziale Gerechtigkeit Migration das
Spektrum ist breit und darauf angelegt
Unzufriedenheit zu nutzen für das neue
Bündnis vom linken bis zum rechten Rand
wir bringen eine Partei an den Staat
damit all die Menschen die auch a Wut
aus Verzweiflung aber eben nicht weil
sie recht sind jetzt darüber nachdenken
AFD zu wählen oder das auch schon
gemacht haben damit diese Menschen eine
seriöse Adresse haben das Land müsse weg
von einem so Wagenknecht blinden ökokurs
die ungeregelte Migration gehöre
gestoppt keine Sanktionen gegen Russland
Positionen der AFD die dadurch Wähler
verlieren könnte die aber gibt sich
gelassen von den Inhalten her muss ich
sagen habe ich mich ein bisschen
gewundert fast eins zu ein AFD also
Verein für Vernunft und Gerechtigkeit so
heißt er jetzt erstmal es gibt eine
Partei für gesunden Menschenverstand das
ist die AFD also von daher ist es ein
weiterer politischer Mitbewerber aber
ich habe jetzt keine angstperlen auf der
Stirn und die Linke nach viel Wut und
Enttäuschung der letzten Tage jetzt der
Blick nach vorn die Neugründung nütze
ihr vielleicht sogar zugleich bedeutet
aber das Ende dieser jahrelangen
Hängepartie eine große Chance für die
Linke
wir sind sehr zuversichtlich dass wir
die linke Partei sein können und die
linke Partei sein werden die jetzt in
dieser Gesellschaft in diesen Zeiten
gebraucht wird ein Wunsch der sich nach
Umfragen eher nicht erfüllen dürfte das
neue Bündnis wirbt jetzt um Spenden und
Unterstützer zur Europawahl will man
erstmals als Partei
antreten the K wie sind die
Erfolgsaussichten einer Sara
wagenknechtpartei
einzuschätzen Deutschland hat ja bisher
anders als beispielsweise Frankreich
oder Österreich keine aktuellen
Erfahrungen mit dieser Form von
personalisierter Partei also da ist von
einer politischen Luftnummer bis hin zu
einer ernsten Erschütterung des
Parteiensystems eigentlich alles möglich
Sarah Wagenknecht und ihre Mitstreiter
kombinieren ja bisher für unvereinbar
gehaltenes linke Sozialpolitik mit
ultrareaktionärer Migrationspolitik also
eine Art politisches Hufeisen wo die
beiden Enden ganz links und ganz rechts
nah beieinander sind linkskonservativer
Populismus wenn es den denn wirklich
gibt der Partei die wird es auf jeden
Fall Schaden allein schon durch den
Verlust von Überläufern und des
Fraktionsstatus allein das verändert
dann die Parteienlandschaft und die neue
Partei dürfte auch für afdwähler
anziehend sein eine Umfrage von heute
abend besagt es jeder siebte afdwähler
künftig Wagenknecht wählen würde aber
weder ist sie für ihr
Organisationstalent bekannt noch für
parlamentarischen Fleiß das Ganze kann
sich also auch sehr schnell wie schon
2018 bei ihrer Bewegung namens auf
Aufstehen wieder in Luft auflösen danke
für diese Einordnung Theo K
gerne schauen wir jetzt auf den Krieg im
Nahen Osten morgen wird es dazu eine
Sitzung des un-serheitsrates geben an
der auch bundesaußenministerin berbock
teilnimmt im Gazastreifen sind seit
Beginn des Krieges auch mindestens 29
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter der
Vereinten Nationen getötet worden meldet
das un Hilfswerk für palästinensische
Flüchtlinge die Menschen in Gaza
bräuchten viel mehr Unterstützung ein
Bericht von Tim
Kröger die Grenze zwischen Ägypten und
dem Gazastreifen auch heute gehen die
Hilfslieferungen weiter ein dritter
Konvoi überquerte den Grenzübergang
Raffa bereits am Wochenende hatten
dutzende Lastwagen Gaza
erreicht es ist vor allem
Krankenhausbedarf Medikamente sind dabei
und Nahrungsmittel wir verteilen das mit
dem palästinensischen roten
halbm
das reiche aber noch nicht so die
Vereinten Nationen die UN fordern
größere Lieferungen unterdessen gehen
die gegenseitigen Angriffe weiter die
Hamas feuerte Raketen in Richtung Israel
ab die israelische Armee Flug in den
vergangenen 24 Stunden laut eigenen
Angaben 320 Angriffe dabei soll laut
Behörden in Gaza wieder viele Tote und
Verletzte gegeben haben laut
israelischen Streitkräften habe man
ausschließlich hamasziele angegriffen
Satelliten Aufnahmen sollen
abschussanlagen zeigen die sich neben
zivilen Einrichtungen wie einem
Kindergarten Schulen einem ungebäude und
einer Moschee befinden vereinzelt haben
die israelischen Streitkräfte in der
vergangenen Nacht offenbar auch
Bodenoperationen in Gaza
durchgeführt in der Nacht gab es
Angriffe von Panzer und
Infanterieeinheiten bei diesen Angriffen
werden trups von Terroristen getötet die
sich auf die nächste Phase des Krieges
vorbereiten
dabei gehe es auch darum Informationen
über die israelischen Geiseln zu sammeln
222 sollen sich in der Hand der Hamas
befinden und in telaviv vergeht kein Tag
an dem nicht an sie erinnert und ihre
schnelle Rückkehr gefordert wird und in
telaviv ist für uns Michael bberunge
Michael die israelische Armee geht jetzt
also schon vereinzelnt mit Bodentruppen
in den gazerstreifen welche Strategie
steckt
dahinter
sowohl die Luftangriffe der letzten Tage
als auch Kommandoaktionen wie der
letzten Nacht werden von der Armee als
konkrete Vorbereitung einer
Bodenoffensive beschrieben bei solchen
Kommandoaktionen geht es darum
Aufklärung zu betreiben vielleicht auch
erste feindliche Stellung auszuschalten
und nicht zuletzt Informationen über den
Verbleib der Geiseln zu gewinnen die
Armee macht nach Berichten Druck auf die
Regierung endlich mit der Bodenoffensive
zu beginnen aber dagegen steht die
geiselfrage die US-Regierung macht Druck
mehr Zeit für Verhandlungen zu geben und
auch die Angehörigen der Geiseln die
hinter mir hier seit Tagen immer wieder
vor dem
Verteidigungsministerium für die
Freilassung der Geisel demonstrieren
machen Druck möglicherweise gibt es
weitere Bewegung es gibt eine Meldung
aus den USA nachdem Qatar konkret die
Freilassung von weiteren 50 Israelis mit
doppelter Staatsbürgerschaft verhandelt
danke schön Michael
bewerunger angesichts der katastrophalen
Situation für die Zivilbevölkerung in
Gaza ringt die EU um Einigkeit im Umgang
mit Israel und dem Krieg konkret geht es
derzeit um die Forderung nach einem
sofortigen Waffenstillstand aus
humanitären Gründen heute haben darüber
die EU Außenministerin und Minister in
Luxemburg beraten dabei gibt es
erhebliche Meinungsverschiedenheiten
Ulf röer
berichtet Anspannung vor dem Treffen der
Außenminister seit Jahren sucht die EU
eine geschlossene Position zum
Nahostkonflikt der Forderung eines
humanitären Waffenstillstands stehen
Länder wie Deutschland zurückhalten
gegenüber außministerin berbock betont
vor allem das Recht Israels auf
Selbstverteidigung es wird nur Frieden
und Sicherheit für Israel und die
PalästinenserInnen und Palästinenser
geben wenn der Terrorismus bekämpft wird
Deutschland die Europäische Union steht
solidarisch an der Seite von Israel und
tut zleich alles dafür dass das
menschliche Leid in Gaza gelindert wird
die Lage für die Zivilbevölkerung in
Gaza spitzt sich zu die Hilfe kommt aber
sie reicht nicht aus einige Staaten in
der EU fordern nun deshalb einen
humanitären Waffenstillstand sprechen
davon dass Israels Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung nicht grenzenlos
sei jetzt ist die Zeit für einen
Waffenstillstand und wenn wir einen
Waffenstillstand erreicht haben dann
müssen wir dafür sorgen dass die ganze
Region nicht im Chaos
versinkt nicht im Chaos versinken das
gilt auch für das andere große Thema den
Krieg in der Ukraine mancher Minister
befürchtet die vielen Krisen könnten den
Westen
überfordern wir können wirklich stolz
sein dass wir die Ukraine so lange nach
allen Kräften unterstützt haben wir
müssen aber jetzt uns den Anforderungen
und den vielen Krisen in der Welt
stellen wir müssen uns oh um die Ukraine
kümmern als auch um Israel und die
Palästinenser die EU Außenminister
suchen weiter nach Geschlossenheit in
schwierigen
Zeiten und wir blicken in die Ukraine
dort sind Millionen Menschen auf der
Flucht vor dem Krieg viele gehen ins
Ausland andere bleiben und suchen
innerhalb ihres Heimatlandes einen
sicheren
Zufluchtsort viele von ihnen hoffen dass
die Stadt leviv früher Lemberg im Westen
der Ukraine solcher Ort ist von dort
berichtet Anne
brü zwischen den Wohnblocks haben sie
ihren Platz gefunden 1000 Menschen leben
im Containerdorf in leevv Frauen Kinder
ältere weil sie hoffen dass Sie hier
sicherer
sind wir haben in einem neunstöckigen
Haus gewohnt es wurde von einer Granate
getroffen wir wollen zurück aber zu
Hause gibt es fast nichts alles ist
weg lwi im Westen der Ukraine ist seit
Beginn des Kriegs Anlaufstelle für
Flüchtlinge Zwischenstation auf dem Weg
Richtung Europa aber viele sind auch
geblieben leben und arbeiten jetzt
hier durch L sind insgesamt 5 Millionen
binenvertriebene gezogen es gab Tage da
hatten wir hier 2 Millionen das heißt
dass praktisch alle Einwohner der Stadt
Binnenflüchtlinge beherbergt haben jetzt
ist die Situation geregelter jetzt
wohnen hier 1500 unserer Landsleute
und die Solidarität in der Stadt ist
groß ich denke so ist das Leben sie
haben keinen Platz wo sie hin können sie
sollen hier in L sein wosonst es gibt
hier nur einen Schuldigen
Russland in der Stadt packen alle mit an
hier entsteht gerade eine neue Schule
aus dem 3D
Drucker es ist schneller günstiger und
es gibt die Möglichkeit dadurch Trümmer
zu
[Musik]
recyceln auf die Zukunft setzen trotz
Krieg in leevv glauben Sie
daran weil ein Menschen getötet und drei
weitere schwer verletzt haben soll muss
sich ein 27-jähriger Syrer vor dem
Oberlandesgericht Düsseldorf wegen
Mordes und versuchten Mordes
verantworten der mutmaßliche is-anhänger
wollte laut Anklage einen Beitrag zum
weltweiten Jihad leisten und Ungläubige
töten im April soll er in der Duisburger
Altstadt einen 26-jährigen mit einem
Messer getö tötet haben wenige Tage
später habe er dann in einem Duisburger
Fitnessstudio wahlos auf Besucher
eingestochen die größte deutsche
Gewerkschaft die ige Metall wird
erstmals in ihrer Geschichte von einer
Frau angeführt Christiane Benner ist
heute mit sehr großer Mehrheit auf dem
Gewerkschaftstag ins Amt gewählt worden
als Nachfolgerin von Jörg Hofmann das
wichtigste Ziel der igemall für die
kommenden Jahre ist die Beschäftigung zu
sichern beim Umbau zum klimaneutralen
produzieren mehr von Markus
wseer Wandel ist weiblich Christiane
Benner feiert ihren großen Moment mit
einer klaren Botschaft kurz zuvor war
die 55-Jährige zur ersten Chefin in der
Geschichte der IG Metall gewählt worden
mit einem starken Ergebnis
96,4% der Delegierten stimmten für Sie
Benner gibt sich kämpferisch wir
befinden uns mitten im größten Umbau
unserer Industrie seit 100 Jahren wir
vertreten über 5 Millionen Menschen
Industrie und Handwerk sie alle brauchen
eine Perspektive unsere Industrie in
Deutschland muss weiterentwickelt werden
und nicht abgewickelt Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Ben sieht ihre Aufgabe auch
darin mit mehr Mitbestimmung die
politische Radikalisierung zu bekämpfen
es sei etwa wichtig rechte Gruppierungen
aus Betriebsräten
fernzuhalten dieses Land braucht eine
starke IG Metall gerade jetzt wo wir
klare Kante zeigen müssen für Arbeit für
Zukunft und gegen Rechts Benner kennt
die IG Metall 1988 tritt sie in die
Gewerkschaft ein macht eine Ausbildung
zur Fremdsprachenkorrespondentin bei
einem Maschinenbauer engagiert sich als
Jugendvertreterin später studiert sie
Soziologie 2011 dann Vorstandsmitglied
der igemetall 2015 Vizechefin unter Jörg
Hofmann der lobt seine Nachfolgerin wir
schlagen Christiane vor weil sie
kompetent ist weil sie die Strahlkraft
nach innen und außen hat die Metall gut
zu präsentieren der Job an der Spitze
der Mächtigen und männerdinierten IG
Metall für Christiane Benner der
Höhepunkt einer langen
gewerkschaftskarriere Benner will die IG
Metall und ihre 2,2 Millionen Mitglieder
nun sichtbarer machen sie scheue nicht
das Licht der Öffentlichkeit verspricht
die neue
Vorsitzende für Unternehmen ist es
schwieriger geworden an neue Kredite zu
kommen die Banken sein zurückhaltender
geworden berichten gut 29% der Firmen
laut Umfrage des ifo Instituts kommen
Unternehmen schwerer an Geld für ihre
Investitionen wird es für die Wirtschaft
schwieriger aus der Rezession
herauszufinden denn Konsum und Export
lahmen zurzeit in Meppen war heute der
statschuss für ein wichtiges
Infrastrukturprojekt die erdkabelttrasse
a nord beim spartenstich legte auch
Bundeswirtschaftsminister habbeck Hand
an die rund 300 km lange Leitung soll
künftig 2 Gigawatt an Windstrom vom
ostfriesischen emten bis ins
nordrheinwestfelis Meerbusch osterrad
transportieren das würde dem
Energiebedarf von ca 2 Millionen
Menschen
entsprechen und jetzt komen wir zum
Fußball Norbert da rollt ja ab morgen
wieder Champions League dabei ja die
Bayern auch in der Königsklasse stark
fahren zu galatasarai Istanbul und Union
auch in der Königsklasse schwach
empfängt SSC Neapel nach acht Berliner
Pflichtspiel Niederlagen in Serie geht's
also gegen Italiens
Meister die Champions League bisher
gelinde gesagt Blutdruck steigernd der
unioncoach und sein Team mussten Last
Minute Niederlagen hinnehmen in Madrid
bei Real und gegen die Portugiesen aus
Braga haben wir den fußballg irgendwie
beleidigt dass wir aktuell so behandelt
werden ob der angeschlagene gosens auch
im Spiel als ballschlepper wirken kann
fraglich Trainer Fischer undverdrossen
trotz der inzwischen acht
Pflichtspielniederlagen in
Serie ich glaube es ist erste Mal so
wirklich stürmisch Italiens Meister
Neapel würde mit einem Erfolg den
Berliner Herbststurm am Leben erhalten
es ist ein weiterer Versuch den wir
Unternehmen wieder in die Spur
zurückzufinden in die Spur könnten sie
kommen vorausgesetzt das Ziel schießen
ist genauso
treffsicher zur Fußballbundesliga da
hatten gestern zwei Trainer gut lachen
Augsburg Coach Jess torup mit einem 5 Z2
einstandsieg in Heidenheim ja und
Steffen Baumgart der feierte den ersten
Kölner Saison Erfolg 3:1 gegen
Gladbach Kölner Freudentränen dieser
Sieg war wichtig und
erkämpft wir waren aggressiv und giftig
haben mitball und guten Fußball gespielt
war die klar bessere Mannschaft und die
Kölner Führung gelang schnell mit ein
bisschen Glück 11 mE nach Handspiel des
gladbachers con das 1:0 durch Florian
Keinz
Minute Köln chancenreich Gladbach
verunsichert wechselte stellte um und
schien mit dem anstusstreffer in der 63
Minute wieder fokussiert nach roter
Karte gegen con war Köln dann aber im
Vorteil und nach diesem faulelfmeter
wieder in Führung 76 Minute wieder keins
zum 2:1 das dritte Tor für Köln gelang
dann kurz vorschluss durch Luca
waldschmid also Kölner Sieg im 97 Derby
gegen
Gladbach und alle Höhepunkte des achten
Spieltags zu sehen bei heute.de und in
der heute App danke schön und zum
Schluss haben wir noch die jüngsten
Erkenntnisse über den Mond wobei jung
passt nicht ganz er ist nämlich 40
Millionen Jahre älter als gedacht bei
Untersuchungen von Mondstaub stieß ein
internationales Team von Forscherinnen
und Forschern auf Kristalle die auf ein
Mindestalter von 4,46 Milliarden Jahren
schließen lassen damals traf ein
Asteroid die Urerde aus den entstandenen
Trümmern formte sich der Mond seitdem
hat er sich aber ganz gut
gehalten regnerisches und mildes
Herbstwetter wartet uns morgen und in
den nächsten Tagen mehr dazu gleich von
Katja hornfer um 21:45 Uhr läuft das
heute journal mit Dunja Hayali machen
sie es
[Musik]
gut guten Abend das wird eine milde
windige und regnerische Herbstwoche
Morgen zieht das Tief Santos hier weiter
Richtung Nordsee dann folgt ein weiteres
namenloses tief hier von Frankreich
hinterher und südwestlich von Island
entwickelt sich schon morgen ein neues
Tief das sich hier einkringelt das Tief
Jussuf das könnte uns zum Ende der Woche
zunächst in Großbritannien dann aber
auch in Mitteleuropa Sturm bringen es
ist ja derzeit noch ziemlich warm die
Wassertemperaturen sind hoch am
Mittelmeer liegen die bei 23 bis
27° und so ist es auch am Land sehr warm
zum Teil noch mit bis zu 30° in
Nordwesteuropa ist es deragegen kühler
bei 5 bis 15° und das sind auch so
ungefähr unsere Nachttemperaturen die
sinken auf 12 bis 5° im Westen breitet
sich Regen aus und der erreicht morgen
Vormittag bereits die Küste anfänglich
zeigt sich hier im Osten noch die Sonne
dann kommt neuer Regen von Südwesten
hinterher der breitet sich nordostwärts
aus dann kann es westlich des Rheins am
Nachmittag schon wieder auflockern der
Wind dazu kommt aus südlichen Richtungen
und deswegen bleibt es auch morgen sehr
mild bei uns mit Werten von 11 bis 17°
und ganz geht's es in den nächsten Tagen
weiter nicht komplett unfreundlich guten
Abend